Now we're in line for The Shining Maze at
Halloween Horror Nights.
This is the number 1 thing that I was looking
forward to.
Right over there is the entrance to the Hedge
Maze I'm gonna be looking for all the references,
all the spooks, all the stuff.
All the RedRum.
Redrum!
I don't suppose they told you anything in
Denver about the incident we had up here in
Winter of 1970?
I'm so stoked for this.
We're gonna give the mixtape to Jack Nicholson.
RedRum!
Come and play with us Danny.
For ever.
And ever.
Mr Halloran, what's in room 237?
Great party, isn't it?
Here's Johnny!
You are the caretaker.
There were like 3 Jack Nicholsons.
It was definitely the best one that we've
done today.
There were a lot of cool references, there
was a lot of cool stuff to look at.
That map of the maze, and all the pictures
on the walls were cool to look at.
They had the elevator, they didn't do it like
I thought they would do it, they had the twins,
of course they had "Here's Johnny!", the bear
costume, "Great party isn't it", so there
were a lot of cool references, I was pretty
happy with it.
Good chance that I'm extremely biased because
it is my favorite movie but I thought it was
fun.
The Shining Maze was my favorite maze so far.
I screamed a lot and I almost cried, but it
was really really good.
I just feel like they could have incorporated
more live people instead of props, and also
do the elevator scene different, but other
than that it was really good.
Thumbs up.
So far it was the scariest maze we've gone
through, but we still have a couple more mazes
left.
They didn't take my mixtape.